so so this is the the time we hung out
was probably five six years ago before
that or how long have you known her did
you is this the girl that did you meet
her on thrinder yes
i married that woman you're married
what's thrinder oh i will tell you
should i tell you i i feel weird telling
your daughter in front of you she's old
enough
she's old enough got done talking about
jeremy having
possible sex with his barber so go ahead
it's at home sex with his brother it's
his nurse his nurse cut his hair yeah
it's all right when you say barber nurse
i feel like he's like in the old west
where the barber just did everything
so did your barber also take the bullet
slab out of your back
okay i got it i get it explain to my
daughter what thrinder is oh she's
married with two kids okay so you're not
gonna hop on this thing or maybe you
will i don't know so uh
i'll do the quick story um thrender uh
and just so you know i'm not lying uh
it's not called thrender anymore because
tinder sued them for copyright
infringement uh now the uh app is called
field f-e-e-l-d if you're uh uh if
you're a adventurous person you may you
may want to remember that name field is
tinder but it's specifically designed
for people trying to have threesomes
oh
not
not really for people that are looking
not the bear not the bear grylls kind of
adventuresome right yeah yeah threesomes
okay so i was on there
and i matched with two women and we were
all gonna go out together did they know
each other those two they did not uh you
you can go on as a single and match with
singles you can go on as a couple and
look for a single to join you right uh i
went on as a single match with two other
singles one of the women did not show up
we still don't know why and the other
one i had a lovely time with and two and
uh two years after that i proposed that
woman because when you find a hot asian
that loves three ways you lock that down
how many times have i told you that
jackie
how many times as your father have i
told you that
you know that's the title for this
podcast
the third one never showed up third one
never showed up for that particular date
or ever really we never really met up
with with her but what a happy ending no
pun intended i mean i mean was that an
asian joke
yes a very happy ending i ended up i
ended up marrying that woman and now we
have a child together so i i and now the
threesome continues oh no that's
terrible
but yeah
it's a it's a crazy thing i i i feel
like field should reach out to me and i
should be the spokesman like hey
i know you're trying for really
adventurous crazy fun sex but you could
have a family life yeah people should be
on field they're looking at the wrong no
why why are you why are you going on the
tinders and the in the [ __ ] and the
farmers only because the field people
are probably more you're more apt to get
a relationship because they're shooting
for the numbers right if i got three
people in one of them is going to be the
perfect match
instead of one-on-one what have you
tried
healed the field
my mouth is full
because he's trying to feel he's trying
that's something you're often saying if
you're on field now on the field do you
specify do you specify you you're
looking for two women like how do you
know you're not gonna yes that's what
that that you can specify the genders uh
if you so wish uh i i specified uh two
women because uh i've i've been a part
of a devil's threesome before but i
wouldn't not for me it's not my thing is
that what it's called the devil's street
them when there's two guys yeah because
the horns
the two horns i don't know that or you
could call it that you can call it the
uh
eiffel tower uh the eiffel tower yeah i
don't get that analogy because it's two
guys uh meeting in the middle and and
the woman's kind of the base between
them i see that so very very european
yeah that's why it's called the eiffel
tower um
uh
because when i engaged in that activity
uh the other man was a tall man i called
mine the leaning tower of pisa
you know because it can't
structurally eiffel tower wouldn't work
so how did that work so there was
another guy there was a woman yeah
yeah that wasn't a fun night
it was an ideal situation
did you accidentally get into it or you
knew you were getting into it i mean i
i didn't start off my night going all
right this is this is happening this is
the day like it's just it it's something
that that happens after a show between
uh
consenting between
all consenting adults a waitress her
husband and then they just wanted to try
something i guess and i was young and in
my 20s i thought
why not let's go let's have a let's have
a great so what goes wrong tell me what
goes wrong ah the paintbrush
what
yeah
go ahead
people don't understand that there is an
art to threesomes
what's the paintbrush
come on you know the paintbrush um okay
so here's my tip when you're in
which is what i said before the devil's
three way
here's my tip uh but
when you're when you're involved with
one of this with with one of these
things which is fine people do what they
do um
if you're
one of the men it is important to
communicate to the other man
what is your
what is your rotation
are like are you how are you switching
positions in in what position are you
switching are you doing clockwise are
you doing counterclockwise oh yeah i did
it dude
direction is very i got over here doing
something like that wait so you say
there's a lot of communication involved
a lot of communication involved no so
just to slow it down for sure our
audience in croatia you know we're
number one no but we are we're number 25
there number 25 of croatia we are and in
trinidad and in lebanon wow yeah that is
that that is amazing okay so
number one through 24 in croatia is just
tennis podcasts
you guys are number 25. that's it that
was the nicest stereotype but i think
the take i think the takeaway is we're
an educational podcast absolutely okay
so you're in a you've said okay to this
couple the waitress her husband and the
couple yes
you go over there are ground rules yes i
don't understand what a paint brush is
wait i'm getting
there will be a payoff no but i mean i
mean the thing is that you say you're
all fully dressed when you get to
wherever the place is when did the
conversations of like i will start in
this office and then i need to move
counterclockwise to this next orifice so
follow my signal what i'm saying is you
should have those conversations oh you
didn't i failed to have those
conversations and that was my first
mistake because it's really hard like
you do her in the mouth
yeah yeah and then we'll move
counterclockwise yes that's what you
should be saying don't don't talk and
talk nicely in front of my kid
instead
uh
instead it it it was the action going on
and then uh the action's going on slow
down so you get did you do it at their
house no we did it in uh my hotel room
and thankfully i had two
uh uh queen beds that time so we did it
in the one bed and then i never touched
that bed for the rest uh for for the
rest of the stay at that particular
comedy club why did somebody make a poo
on the bed no it was just uh i just
didn't bad memories yeah yeah i just
want to be in the i just want to be in
the other bed well thank god that's the
good news so there was a there was clean
linen
for you clean linen involved yeah so
okay so you get to your hotel room yes
is there any conversation about who goes
first where we go or they went first
just alone and you're watching
yes and i didn't know that that was
going to happen you didn't know no well
you were just saying there's no
communication yeah but the point is i
just figured that i'm trying to get
inside the minds of you and your friends
right the the the key was you just put
on a show for them they came from a
comedy club yeah they just performed for
them and they said hey
and sometimes and
it
almost never goes to this point but i'm
sure you've been in a club where you
hang out with the staff afterward you
talk you ha you have a beverage whatever
so uh they offered and that's it right
dad
right and that's it and then this
particular time they they they offered
to give me a ride back
and uh so i was like that's what you
heard yeah she said ride my back
so
we're in the we're in the hotel room
where we're we're having like one last
drink in my hotel room they begin to
engage okay and i'm just kind of like
with each other not with you not with me
right and i was like oh okay
that's happening in my room okay all
right
and then
the uh
and then the woman indicated that she
would like me to join in and at that
point clockwise or counterclockwise how
do you approach that
i approach it by looking at uh the
husband and being like
is this a like is this a thing like or
am i gonna because the the she was a
very attractive woman i was i i i was
into her
that she was very fine the guy not my
type uh mostly the penis and balls
not my type for some people it's great
for for others
not not so much and um but i kind of
looked at him like hey is this something
that's okay because the last thing you
want to do is engage in that kind of
activity and and and while the woman
might be into it the husband wasn't
aware or didn't know and then right
people don't think you're opening up a
whole new there are certain
um kind of uh preferred um
practices involved because i didn't
realize
if i would see that you might just
enter without the proper signal yes and
so you said to him like hey is this okay
and he goes he goes yeah we do this all
the time i'm like oh oh that makes it
even better okay so all right we do this
definitely should jump in a vat of
purell after this but okay uh
and now did you get do you put on
protection yes like a helmet yeah yeah
yeah yeah of course helmet helmet wrist
guards
the whole the shin guards
now you're just being silly
so we're we're engaged in the leaning
tower of pisa and i'm trying to figure
out what the leaning tower of pisa for
those people that aren't creative and
the reason i'm telling you is that
jeremy our uh editor
will uh make he puts a lot of this in
animation so
describe it i want to see what this
looks like
he's gonna he's gonna what are you
saying the guy that cleans the fish tank
in the
in the in the last in there listening he
was listening to this sure he is i'm
sure he's having and he just came back
he wants to know everybody wants to know
what the leaning tower is something
jeremy could draw really easily yeah
describe like penthouse form for him
right now yeah uh
the the leaning tower of pisa so the so
the eiffel tower is uh
it's kind of too
even based the lean tower pizza with me
being smaller you had the one guy
way taller than me and he's she's
standing uh no she's uh she's on all
fours like doggy styles yeah well one of
us i get it i get what it is no no no i
don't want to hear you
when your daughter goes oh like doggy
style i get it
there's nothing that bothers nothing
about them
yeah like when you snowball someone
right exactly i don't know snowball oh
thank christina
[Music]
you